Kristen Stewart gets candid about her ex
Robert Pattinson and her love life now
the T magazine covergirl opens up about
her former romance with her Twilight
co-star telling the mag quotes people
wanted me and Rob to be together so
badly that our relationship was made
into a product it wasn't real life
anymore and that was gross to me it's
not that I want to hide Who I am or hide
anything I'm doing in my life it's that
I don't want to become a part of a story
for entertainment value as long as we
both shall live
I've gotten to a point where I don't
feel like so guarded but at the same
time I'm good at not allowing my the
details of my life to be trivialized
the Twilight alum is currently dating
producer Alicia cargile and says she's
more comfortable talking about her
private life in sexuality quote I would
never talk about any of my relationships
before but once I started dating girls
it seemed like there was an opportunity
to represent something really positive I
still want to protect my personal life
but I don't want to seem like I'm
protecting the idea
I'm definitely getting more comfortable
because I just don't care